hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
we're on part 4 already can you believe
it a quick note about this one we go
into sewers on this episode and it gets
so dark it's ridiculous so if you're
watching on mobile
make sure you crank up your brightness
it will help so much who really really
will
ok so I'll shut up and we'll pick up
from where we got to last time whoo
so chapter one finished done and dusted
we are out of the precinct Leon does not
look at it go on Leon there you go fella
feel better so a dough we want answers
unfortunately no Ben didn't come through
well what exactly are you looking for
more info on the people responsible for
this mess what about you trying to save
those are you looking at I told the
tenant brand overhearing help getting
that feels so good to be outside where
we going boss
gunshot kendo I remember this in 1998
it's locked love can't get in you got
another plan
oh are you the master of unlocking nice
nice
are we just pillaging them like all good
police men do okay oh is it that a
coincidence it's a long barrel here boom
shaka lakh ready to break [ __ ] what
else can we steal is this what gun shops
are like in America just walk around and
grab anything you like
or they all behind cabinets like I hurt
you I said don't move I'm just passing
through I'm gonna ask you to lower that
weapon I kill you I go right back out
the way you can know that kiddies a
zombie I think your daughter needs help
sir tell me how to deal with my daughter
drop it no wait
step aside when you determinate her
before she call y'all on a parent are
you low family
that's my [ __ ] daughter yeah just let
them a bit of compassion from liang's
Emma sweetheart sweetheart I told you to
stay put
oh she's changing what they did to us
you're a cop you're supposed to know
something how did this happen
huh she was a sweet little angel
I was sleeping oh I'm gonna put you to
bed - okay
is he gonna kill his own doctor
[Music]
she said all
excuse some privacy whenever I watch
things like this when I was younger they
never hit me but now now I'm a dad no no
I have a kids it's one thing to keep the
truth from me but why him oh my god you
just shut up I want to find out what's
happening here and stop whoever's behind
it helping people like them that's why I
joined the force
huh my mission is to take down on
Bella's entire operation we may not make
it out whatever it takes to save this
city
count me in
whoa well that was touching that
reminded me of the Last of Us it was
that good to be honest but yeah I never
used to understand scenes like that
until until I had to kid myself and yeah
he does hit show when you see that kind
of suffering but anyway we're not here
for that operation there are
pharmaceutical companies secretly making
bio weapons they have a virus it turns
people into indestructible monsters that
explains the horrible things I've seen
indestructible monsters we've gone out
it's called the education system X teach
you by the way right is this where we go
to the sewers and that's why I'm looking
for a net Birkin she's the one at
umbrella responsible for unleashing the
virus I'm going to bring her down count
me in love as long as you take that
stupid ass jacket off cuz I don't
stilettos
dang girl get to that based on what
you've said the server seems fitting
well said after you
gee thanks gee do people really say that
gee thanks
I hope they do I like to look Williams
this is damn doc can't imagine a real
scientist being down here
according to HQ come on sewers are run
by the city how could they have a
facility without the authorities knowing
welcome to portrait America umbrellas
control dresses nervous
oh that earthquake
sounds like my girlfriend on the toilet
Hey
here for the jokes that's the alligator
oh okay I'm edgy now are you coming
don't let me go my own low thank you
[Music]
okay we're gonna fight we're gonna fight
an alligator again I presume this is
what happened in all-american 50s again
no chance you're stuck with me to the
end
oh right let's fight ah you sure this is
the right way
unfortunately I let it be their turd
owns it this is it
what do we do what do we do okay run
runnin runnin and runnin runnin and
runnin runnin and runnin runnin and just
don't everything
okay so we just yeah I agree we just
switch sides when he gets near
in the original we blew him up with a
canister of something that explodes
[Music]
wait wait wait
this is what I was talking about night
[ __ ]
that was so damn cool that was so damn
cool chew on that you overgrown son of a
[ __ ] neat which is all right that was
the coolest thing I've done in a long
time I know it was only like 12 seconds
of effort but that is so damn good
you missed it did you see me did you see
me ADA SEC he was like and I was like
I'll blow you up
he was like I was like yeah you know
impressed I'm gonna make my move on you
soon
you said the virus turned people into
monsters not no missiles fair point I'm
just impressed you made it in one piece
hey I'm quite impressed too I'm great
hey he's I must be hurting holding his
gun that high off all the time I can't
make it work love well you know okay so
let me get this straight
umbrella sells monsters like that to who
our military somebody else's they don't
sell the monsters they sell the viruses
that make them and Annette is who makes
viruses
scary's that alligator was an X far more
dangerous
right a networking anything to pick up
hello savepoint my favorite place in the
world are you locked out yeah stay out
you're not welcome here this is quite
fully are you with get on my way I'm
only kidding
okay okay I'll play the game definitely
Williams head your work identify
yourself
I'm not Birkin she's who we're looking
for
not much time need to dispose of it
we're here for the g-virus
that's not gonna happen I'm warning you
doctor
oh yeah hey pyromania you cannot shoot
for [ __ ] woman didn't expect that from a
scientist
Leon forget about me just go stop her
before she gets away
Oh shot in the shoulder you're not gonna
die
nope changing clothes changing clothes
this is it yeah girl do you a cigarette
nice mouth
it's not on her it must be in the mist
crimson head
she's definitely got the correct attire
for the job at hand
once it's in hand I'll call for
extraction we are ADA run run
Annette but you can't hide okay what are
we doing going through the air ducts oh
this is our electromagnetic field
visualizer so we can have shizzle its
secret weapon time sequin about there so
you follow the blue stuff and then do
this noise
how do we gain alright then you explode
it
did you see me Liam I was so cool you
have a nice sleep candy from a baby
there's a weird thing to randomly say
candy from a baby don't eat yellow snow
right so use this to find you to find
the PowerPoint which turns it on which
were then overheat
right we're trained now let's do that
we've some enemies around now perfect
the door leads to that is Elvis was this
a into the aidid response there we go
we're looking for ID wristbands crack
off nine bullets in her peashooter
zombies right house of light goes round
there it goes round this is gonna be a
labyrinth can you just come over here
please sir over here a little bit not
too fast
whoa I wasn't expecting to be mounted
look at that left hook go girl
I rode
what okay that that's did it surprise me
a little bit
do we shake it like do the stanky leg
yeah around them come over you dude I
need to go behind you and I don't want
to waste any more bullets okay we're
good this gang killing she's hardcore
ada you're my favorite person in the
world go gillich visualising there it is
okay the lift should work now thank ya
yellow here we go I'm one hit from death
this is not good
good good no more jump scares hope we go
well there's a net got you now I don't
think we do always been good at running
a net give you that we're good at
hobbling faster we literally could have
just jumped over that barrier there you
still question it resident evil
the way the left just went back down
again what the hell was that are you
joking
persistent bastard aren't you there's no
electricity how do I turn this back on
can I use that one
he's right behind me there's nothing
that there's nothing out I'm dead okay
what do you think we do i dad
doesn't work scan and he goes all the
way to the little yeah we we have to
dodge him
staggers staggers after three my still
oh I'm sorry staggers after three
staggers up to three one do three run
yeah
- good for you mate - good for you mate
and go what what what I don't think
we're supposed to go this perfect god
sake okay I may be overthinking that
it's already coming
I persistent bastard aren't you
oh it's that simple stop overthinking
thank you yeah I'll take those thank you
darling all right oh so we have to do it
under pressure now okay okay does it
lead we are petrifying splitting
petrifying leads back there of course
where we just went got it
and zap it dump it dump it it's a bit
quicker than this thank you please be
able to fit yeah you can't get us now
Baldy no no no no no torches everybody
put the lighters up what's next we
really need some heels for no
electricity so we're still doing the
same thing see you Rocky
I promise I'll stop saving at some point
there's an upstairs
inspection wristband incinerator okay so
basically we're going to open an
incinerator there's going to be a
wristband inside something's going to go
wrong and we're going to get trapped in
the incinerator are you ready for that
to happen it'll be a joyous time
and there it is flushing away as soon as
we pick it up though something's going
to trigger how are we going to get drunk
this is just going to randomly show no
it's mrs. Birkin Bravo
please let us out gonna burn me alive
now you'll never get your filthy hands
on the G I'm not going after it you
realize that oh one minute so uh-oh
think this through okay it's all about
gaining access via overpowering
[Music]
goes up there right round up cross and
then Zac please be the right one
okay we need all three we need all three
okay follow it back fold back there
that's one one one two down come on
follow that with background that's
basically just switch this one ten
seconds come on
and hence which these two one nine eight
and then zap this and hope there's
enough time left two point six six
seconds remaining
this [ __ ] knows what she's doing cuz
I'm great mm-hmm I do like that dress
if cross-dressing was allowed on YouTube
in fact nobody knows I could be wearing
that dress right now please return
before this date I think not gonna
happen
I will okay we're now up to twenty saves
ridiculous twenty saves every five
minutes basically this is really day
we've been here before
oh no this is nothing to do here so find
this girl some herbs
must be some somewhere Oh another
cutscene a next stop trying to kill us
nah this cat-and-mouse game the game is
over
you lost tell me
as your husband's still alive
or did you kill him so you could take
credit for cheese interesting theory
you don't walk from the nest
over my dead body so be it
oh good army role she's gonna be [ __ ]
she's not gonna be fine there is a stick
through her leg damn come on more
hardcore than that you don't need a man
to sort it out for you what was that
sure pop she's havin a nap
no night Sweet Cheeks does this mean
Leon will wake up now from his slumber
what where am I I got shot name's Adam
something needa
heydo yeah
dammit find adder
Ayda where are you oh look the Lud is
broken that's where we came from burn
zombie oh now the electricity is on yes
okay let's jump in more feces damn this
is dark smells like home
do you hear something I heard something
trash monsters right left hole all right
hole every hole is a goal but we're
gonna go right
walking through human feces typical
first day in the police
you don't move I can see a maggot don't
think they're waking up put my junk in
his face he wasn't bothered what have
you got
and all digi beta so we need some sort
of VHS player from those people who were
born before 1995 you anything Dollface
legs 11 do the stanky leg oh you're so
cute
you just gave me just gave me dude y'all
gonna wake up okay we have a chest piece
so I presume we have to collect all the
chess pieces or remember where they all
are okay we're going you can keep the
room to yourself
stop shouting I wonder if we can push
them in the roof right come and talk to
you soon
we just need to figure out what on earth
we are doing in the basement sewers
right nice
back in the feces again
there's only one way to go
guess we're going down yeah yeah doc
joking lot is full of it
it's a few floaters everywhere right
yeah cuz people just leave her flying
around everywhere we need some sort of
tool okay what the hell is that
do I shoot it do I walk past it
sighs weak spot hi where's your weak
spots please
is it your face is it your shoulder
patch what the hell is spitting out oh
they're coming for me
they're coming mommy we've all seen that
movie come on these are my sewers that
is definitely not your weak spot oh I
see I see you see
dead okay so we can put grenades inside
them we just wasted every single bullet
we have okay just the Magnum left
cable-car cable car i said interesting
so that's how we get two umbrellas
facility blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah where'd she go hmm i wonder if
these change every single games not they
don't like bugs okay where am I going
shotgun shells always welcome what am I
missing in here has to be a way out this
way
oh I'm so dense why do I always miss
these oh well we're go right now just
cut out the last 20 oh that doesn't
sound good
I think Williams around and his wish
Wellington's I like the sound of that
like me and pop music
don't mind us down at that
either someone's discarded a Nader
I'm coming ADA whoa got excited fast all
right I've got some bleach on the table
we can save again if we need to okay a
pamphlets lovely oh we can see what's on
the tape so this should be from one of
those little security guards well the
virus I'll bet those rats spread it you
are not wrong
so this requires electricity why doesn't
so where to Leon would you fancy doing
picking up some flowers
lovely you got full health yeah is
that's all we need
[ __ ] where do we need it for was it in
the sewers can we get on injury okay
good to know thank you
side of the safe is in chalk okay so if
we see a safe the the number or
combination is on the side
oh that's looking that's lucky you
stayed dead mister and on the side to
twelve eight hi I always forget they
have to go the opposite direction to
twelve act yeah just like a stock for
our shotgun go on Betsy you're looking
damn sexy girl I would like that over
there but I don't want to risk the
bullets or the illness you can keep that
flower sir we will meet again
get him pissed on the job you sure we're
not in Britain
Oh Frankie now let's get the crud on me
dude yep yep that aim sucks donkey balls
well done oh I'm out the bullies what a
waste
oh yes this is when you need mouse and
keyboard or accuracy fortnight's ruined
me you don't have to get near the target
to hit it on for night
oh you know some more eat this
you stay in dead mate come alive later
on come alive
here we go a tool using a tool whoa it's
like a scene out of aliens we got a key
what's the key for though a sewers key
yeah
so the chess set we need to pick up all
those little chess pieces we've seen so
far so I presume there'll be a king a
queen
Brook Drumm boil rock is is a rocker
Castle it is isn't it
this door is impossible to get into
should we go down yeah go on we'll go
down
what the really zillions what the hell
was there we have similar reactions me
and you Leon what the hell
we get up here oh that's far too much of
a stretch for our Leon
it must be a way through though no we're
definitely missing something down here
because we have to get to the supplies
room to the hostel oh yes oh my god this
is getting worse
speaking itself pass quite happy with
that anybody down here we've moved
quickly through water okay darling
Christmas presents for you
anymore for anymore
we have ready for action while still
doing that we will Bob through and it's
a dead end great okay yeah yeah we'll
take bullets thank you very much yeah
staying common running away
sugar
yeah we got this coming up you wouldn't
dare
another one of those raccoons don't know
how many we've got looks like a puzzle
with more of those chess pieces by the
looks of it so to get in here we need a
king plug what was the other one
was it a castle
but this has the Queen it's a queen now
isn't it yeah that's a queen and it
locks that door to get in here is the
Queen again it's good that locked over
there that's not a door Adam you idiot
so everything is locked down
Oh lame thrower oh I want it we need to
bring the King key over here to get that
what
please don't say I'm hearing things now
thank you thank you
now that locks okay so we have to jump
down what is that zombie
you're sleeping now so we can
concentrate so this one now if we put
the Queen back in and then put the King
one in here we should get a flamethrower
for our troubles lovely look at the size
of it this is awesome
can we take these with us I've got a
feeling we're going to need them oh this
does lockers now
[Music]
security we can get this we can get all
these keys do you think we need them
I'm regarding between regret this aren't
type because we gain electronic parts
please remember they're there anyway
we'll come back for them if we need them
not a fan of that are you nothing left
to do in here now we're just gonna run
through this if that's all right save
our bullets hang on where's the way out
I'll lay on climb okay this is different
way out get out of me get out of it I
guess we have to kill you then Mike
Tyson
the line
so right now it's okay and we're out
jobs in Gooden okay
I'm really sorry
when you look you looked too aggressive
you sleep with the fishes and the
floating [ __ ]
Leon me when you're not strong now be
your friend somebody - Leon where the
hell did we go next
I haven't got a clue we all need oh bomb
rank honor I think that's some sort of
shielding our immunity I should have
read the book about combining herbs you
know what sit down
typical soon as you get health it's over
they want you dead
the undead wants you dead oh great
two of them great this one alive
hey Bernhard we are progressing well
Leon I'm proud of you
we lost down here it's the 22nd save
okay we have what the hell is this so to
get in here we need to put plugs in
sockets
yeah has to be those little chess pieces
dammit I knew we should have taken them
at the time right we've got with the
horsey things called the horse at night
goes in here okay the king in the Queen
from where we got the flamethrower and
the little castle piece from the
original lifts yes Adam in edit just cut
around here and just bring all the
pieces back because double-tracking back
is gonna be so boring to watch
especially quicker than I thought to be
honest so we have all six we have six
now just in case I did make that edit we
have six pieces to figure out where the
effect they go but on the wall pretty
sure the rook and the knight are on the
same wall and the bishop and the queen
ant next to each other the Queen and the
rook were opposite each other too
well if we start with the pieces that we
do know so we've got the night and when
the night is in the right place the
night is in the right place so the brook
has to be on this wall somewhere which
is there next bit was the bishop and
queen can't be next to each other and
the Queen and the rook were opposite so
the Queen has to be there
how's that yeah okay almost there inna
we're coming for you as Booker T would
say yeah I'll take your herbs it looks
like a fight we're getting herbs hello
ADA damn it
need the power on/off bua okay
everywhere is locked
dead dead and more this we're gonna get
attacked we got all three herbs within
20 seconds right we need the red bar to
be filled that doesn't work that's far
too powerful
okay okay okay what if we do this and
that no okay no no no yeah no
okay let's die again that and that no
that no that and that yeah okay what are
we doing something's going to attack got
on my Jesus Mary and Joseph
arch up one of those in your arm okay
one one one one that's fine - one - Adam
three one two of them I've got this
three - just pulling this back is a
tight game
let's go set us on fire and then run
away that's the new tactic that is the
new tactic
[Music]
what is this what is this
move that over what what what what what
do you want me to do game it's fine this
is gonna be good
okay okay and then we'll swing it back
over
come on there is that is gonna be very
useful we'll definitely keep that get
you next time right please press that
button and then we need to find some way
of getting him to stay still about that
yelling like them in the eye
stay down you piece of turd stay down
stay down stay down stay down
what no boy let's do this
are you hitting is annoyed in general
and every time right the buttons ready
to press get him over here press the
button get him over here again and then
shoot him in the eyeball that's our plan
no don't be that close I need a little
bit
I need a gap William personal space
though I could get him to take a knee I
was very wrong we have to make it over
there William that's for you and I'm
gonna press ok I got myself I'm that
skilled let's do this
it's good William stay there William
be a good boy yes don't move brave don't
move do a live William get out William
I've had enough of this fight
[Applause]
[Music]
we did it let's hope that's the last of
them well played well played I really
enjoyed that that was so cool okay we'll
call that the end of the episode how
many episodes is that now four already
we're definitely reaching the end of the
game so come back tomorrow and we'll see
how far through we can get I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you
tomorrow